many years ago the Great British
explorer George Mallory who was to die
on Mount Everest was asked why did he
want to climb it he said because it is
there those spaces they and we're going
to climb it and the moon and the planets
available and New Hope's for knowledge
and peace a day and therefore as we set
sail we ask God's blessing food for on
the most hazardous and dangerous
greatest adventure one week man is ever
involved one
all engine running
[Music]
look at the Stars the Great King asked
looked down on us in the stars
yes so whenever you feel alone just
remember those kings will always be
there to guide you
[Music]
there's a tingling in the spine that
captian the voice a faint sensation as
if a distant memory a fallen of a great
height we know we are approaching the
grandest of mysteries
[Music]
oh those stories written before space
travel but about space captain
how could there have been stories about
space travel before the writers Chris
set made it on
[Music]
what is it you want Mary what do you
want you you want the moon just say the
word and I'll throw a lasso around it
pull it down hey that's pretty good idea
I'll give you the moon all right 104 man
[Music]